bonjour
il faut changer et il faut y mettre les
moyens les moyens économiques
georges marchais vous en a parlé dans sa
précédente émission les moyens
politiques
il y reviendra dans la suite des
émissions se sont essentiellement je
vous le rappelle une majorité populaire
l'union de la gauche
un gouvernement socialiste communiste et
en même temps vos propres luttes avoue
travailleuses et travailleurs cette
politique nouvelle il faudra l'appliquer
dans un cadre international donnait
c'est le marché commun c'est l'europe
c'est ce monde dont giscard d'estaing ne
cesse de dire qu'il est un monde
dangereux
cela a naturellement des conséquences
pour notre industrie pour notre
agriculture
mais les problèmes là aussi on peut les
résoudre
comment c'est ce à quoi georges marchais
se propose aujourd'hui de réfléchir avec
vous il est accompagné d'emmanuel maffre
baugé députés à l'assemblée européenne
responsables professionnels agricoles et
d'andré lajoinie que je ne présente pas
puisqu'il est le président du groupe
communiste à l'assemblée nationale alors
duvernay je dois faire une mise au point
à la suite de l'émission d'avant-hier
mercredi l'émission et fut officielle au
cours de laquelle françois mitterrand a
invité haroun tazieff
ce dernier a prétendu que la dans le
domaine de l'énergie la politique du
parti communiste français était la
politique du tout nucléaire
c'est un mensonge
les françaises et les français savent
les journalistes savent car je les dis
souvent qu'au contraire nous avons une
politique dans ce domaine extrêmement
diversifiée c'est ainsi que lors d'une
conférence de presse que j'ai tenus il y
a plusieurs mois j'ai dit ceci les
objectifs de consommation d'énergie pour
1990 sur la base d'une croissance de 4%
par an donnerait ceci charbon 17,1 pour
cent pétrole 29,3 % gaz
14,6 pour cent énergies nouvelles 5,9
pour cent hydraulique 6,3 pour cent
nucléaire 26,8 pour cent et j'ai
expliqué qu'avec cette politique
extrêmement diversifiés comme vous
pouvez en juger vous même la france qui
ne couvre aujourd'hui que 25% de ses
besoins couvrirait 60 % en 1990 quelle
est la vérité et je me devais de vous le
dire ce soir d'autant plus que vous
savez bien que vois je n'ai pas de
langage
je tient les mêmes propos à bresse à
paris et à perpignan
c'est vrai pour ce qui concerne
l'énergie c'est également vrai pour ce
qui concerne le marché commun quand je
dis non à l'élargissement de l'espagne
on va et au portugal
c'est valable partout emmanuel ans et
fera bouger et bien je voudrais d'abord
dire une chose qui me paraît très
importante pour le monde paysan pour les
français en général c'est que
l'agriculture française est une des plus
grandes richesses de la france
il est diversifié et les compétitive
c'est une agriculture de qualité et
c'est cette agriculture la capsule mans
connaît des difficultés sans précédent
le marché commun givi au coeur de ce
marché commun et je vois chaque jour en
fonction des taxes de coresponsabilité
en fonction d'une politique qui ne tient
pas compte des intérêts paysans pas pu
que les intérêts consommateurs je vois
se déliter notre marché professionnel je
vois que nos pout de production n'arrive
jamais à couvrir non réelle dépenses en
particulier lorsqu il suffit de les
comparer avec les prix de la production
le bilan du marché commun en matière
agricole est donc très mauvais c'est
vrai aussi de l'industrie
évidemment d'ailleurs je crois que cette
là des faits les plus importants de la
campagne actuelle c'est la prise de
conscience parmi les travailleurs de
leurs intérêts communs avec les paysans
l'élargissement à l'espagne et au
portugal aurait des conséquences
extrêmement
négatives pour l'industrie par exemple
pour la construction navale et je
pourrais citer beaucoup d'autres
exemples
par conséquent je pense que il faut bien
comprendre ici c'est toujours la même
loi c'est la course aux profits
capitalistes les monopoles espèrent
trouver dans ces pays une madone et ils
trouveront d'ailleurs une main d'oeuvre
à bon marché qui leur permettrait
d'assurer les profits et ensuite on
importerait chez doux et naturellement
ce serait plus de chômeurs encore pour
les travailleurs français
d'où l'intérêt commun des ouvriers et
des paysans donc catégoriquement non non
au marché commun élargi lui elles sont
nos propositions mais j'en ai dit tout à
l'heure un seul langage alors nos
propositions
évidemment je reviens à mon document que
je vous ai si souvent présentés et bien
je veux résumer simplement très vite
qu'elle est qu'elles sont nombreux
position dans ce domaine premièrement la
france doit rejeter les plans
supranationaux de démantèlement
industriel telles que les plantes
avignon pour l'acier le chantier naval
pour l'automobile maintenant
deuxièmement la france doit lutter pour
modifier la politique agricole commune
et cela en préservant la liberté des
décisions nationales
pas de diktat de bruxelles quel est mon
bonheur des petits tête de la commission
européenne
évidemment évident troisièmement la
france de refuser toute extension des
pouvoirs de l'assemblée européenne
je dis que c'est à l'assemblée nationale
à paris que doivent se décider
les affaires de la france et
quatrièmement la frange bel et bien de
le dire doit repousser l'élargissement
du marché commun tel est notre politique
nous sommes d'accord sur l'élargissement
emmanuel absolument d'accord il faut le
combattre il faut le combattre je dois
dire d'ailleurs que dans cette assemblée
de strasbourg c'est quelque chose
d'invraisemblable c'est une assemblée
caméléon il y allait super caméléon tel
monsieur chez saur faut dire qu'ils
passent leur temps à tenir un double
langage
tantôt lorsqu'ils sont là aussi le
langage de monsieur j tarder
et puis nous les retrouvons aux côtés de
monsieur mitterrand ces choses là
doivent d'être dit
il ya là aussi une double vérité donc un
double mensonge
andré lajoinie que peut-on faire alors
pour l'agriculture française quelles
sont les propositions dont georges
marchais le porter bien georges marchais
le parti communiste propose de donner
une nouvelle jeunesse agriculture
française c'est quoi georges marchais a
été le premier et le seul à dire il n'y
a pas assez de paysans alors qu'est ce
que ça veut dire
bien ça veut dire qu'au lieu de base et
la politique agricole comme le fait le
gouvernement le marché commun sur les
importations de produits alimentaires
des endroits où ils sont les moins chers
y compris là où les paysans meurent de
faim comme au brésil
eh bien nous nous voulons développer
notre potentiel et pour développer ce
potentiel il faut premièrement permettre
aux paysans d'avoir une rémunération
correcte de leur travail c'est à dire
des prix agricoles qui correspondent aux
coûts de production
il faut permettre d'installer des jeunes
car si l'on laisse faire les choses
aujourd'hui nous allons la disparition
natation de la terre pour la rétine nous
laisse nous laissons disparaître les
paysans il faut permettre aux paysans et
aux jeunes d'accéder à athènes la terre
c'est l'outil de travail utile
fondamental de travail à la terre en
propriété ou en location il faut donner
la terre la disposition de la terre à
ceux qui la travaillent et non à des
spéculateurs étrangers ou des gens qui
veulent placer l'orge et il faut
troisièmement une réanimation de la vie
rurale
il faut que cessent ces déserts d'un
village bienvenue l'école la poste
l'épisode mais ne pipe ne peut plus y
demeurer et personne ne peut y vivre un
désert il faut réanimer ces villages et
notamment un régime à l'agriculture mais
aussi en donnant des emplois non
agricoles avec les industries agro
alimentaires ou autres
c'est donc un élément de la relance de
l'économie française de cette relance de
l'économie française georges marchais a
déjà parlé à sa précédente émission
il a montré qu'elle passait avant tout
par le développement du marché intérieur
c'est à dire de la consommation
populaire en france
il a montré aussi qu'elle a des
conditions internationales c'est-à-dire
qu'il faut élargir développer la
coopération de la france la rééquilibrer
avec les pays capitalistes comme
fédéral japon les états-unis l'élargir à
d'autres pays l'élargir avec les pays
socialistes et tout particulièrement
avec le tiers-monde
là c'est une très grande question qui
est posée j'observe d'ailleurs que tout
le monde parle de cette question dans
les discours alors on pas de ces
centaines de millions d'hommes et de
femmes qui ont faim qui connaissent le
sous-développement la misère un enfant
qui meurt toutes les 30 2 secondes parce
qu'il a faim tout le monde en parle
tu l'as vu toi même je les ai vu moi
même puisque j'ai fait plusieurs voyages
à la fois en afrique et en amérique là
c'est insupportable c'est insupportable
mais jeudi qu' il ne suffit pas d'en
parler et il ne suffit pas même si je le
rends hommage organisé des quêtes sur la
place publique pour aider ces gens le
problème qui est posé c'est le problème
d'organiser un nouvel ordre économique
et politique mondiale de quoi s'agit-il
il s'agit au fond de trois choses la
première il faut organiser la solidarité
pour ces gens qui connaissent la
situation dont je viens de parler
deuxièmement il faut procéder à ce que
l'on appelle une nouvelle division
internationale du travail
c'est un mot qui pavin d'un peu barbare
mais c'est ça ce que veulent ces peuples
qui se sont affranchis du colonialisme
c'est ce d'opter du d'économies qui leur
permettra de satisfaire aux besoins de
leurs propres une nouvelle économie y
compris avec des progrès scientifiques
et techniques que nous connaissons
actuellement
oui mais alors georges marchais ce n'est
que justice c'est la voix du coeur qui
viennent se faire entendre ils ont pu
être posés chez nous une question peut
être posée chez nous si on développe ces
pays
si on les industrialise si on les équipe
avec les progrès scientifiques et
techniques
ne vont-ils pas nous concurrencer non
absolument pas j'indique qu'il ya une
troisième une trois choses à faire pour
ce nouvel ordre
il faut démocratiser les institutions
internationales comme le fonds monétaire
international afin de ne pas peser sur
la
liberté politique de ces pays mais
absolument pas sur l'emprise que ça sera
pas plus de show machine mais c'est le
contraire
cela veut dire que aujourd'hui comment
ça se passe aujourd'hui je te donne 100
camions et tu me donnes 100 kg de café
voilà à quoi on ramène le commerce et
les groupes capitalistes absolue main on
a on a 6 % on apporte 6% produits
manufacturés de ces pays
c'est donc ridicule par contre en
développant l'économie de ces pays
nous allons avoir la possibilité d'une
coopération si justice je les montre et
et d'une coopération à un niveau
infiniment plus élevé autrement dit cela
se traduira y compris par la création de
nombreux emplois dans notre propre pays
mais sur une base de justice c'est la
justice et c'est la raison l'intérêt de
mon mari pour cette nouvelle des
chercheurs et celle à venir
c'est la façon de sortir de la crise
c'est l'une des façons étroitement liée
aux mesures à mettre en oeuvre pour
sortir le pays de la crise qu'il connaît
et c'est étroitement liée naturellement
cette conception avec la consolidation
de la paix pas pour le plus longtemps
possible comme a dit hier soir giscard
d'estaing mais pour toujours
absolument mais si on pas dans les
écoutes ont évidemment ils essaient de
créer un climat de peur on les comprend
à la bei est dangereux et bien moi je
dis bien mon n'est pas dangereux pour la
première fois de son histoire le monde a
la possibilité de bannir à tout jamais
la guerre d'ailleurs je vous fais aussi
avec depuis 35 ans
nous n'avons pas de guerre mondiale il
ya des conflits locaux contre lesquels
il faut lutter mais il n'y a pas de
guerre mondiale cela ne veut pas dire
que l'impérialisme a changé de nature
absolument pas mais aujourd'hui
l'impérialisme ne peut plus décider à ta
guise de la guerre ou de la paix parce
qu'il y a un rapport de force en faveur
des forces de paix par conséquent nous
pouvons imposer la paix mais il ya un
surcroît d'armement et même une course
effrénée aux armements qui en plus coûte
très cher au peuple a et c'est là que se
pose alors le problème du rôle de la
france le rôle de la france
oui
le désarmement arrêter la course aux
armements et qu'est ce que la vase peut
faire et ce qu'elle en a les moyens
actuellement la détente la coexistence
pacifique repose sur un équilibre de
forces mais aussi sur une course aux
armements
nous nous disons il faut y mettre un
terme autrement dit il faut qu'à la
détente et à la coexistence pacifique
succède maintenant des mesures concrètes
de désarmement et je pense que une des
critiques les plus fermes que nous
pouvons faire à la politique de giscard
d'estaing c'est de n'avoir pas pris les
initiatives qu'il fallait prendre pour
aller danser forte voire même il
contribue lui même à la course aux
armements par la bombe à neutrons et son
accord avec des fusées nucléaire
américaine nouvelle cuisine huppert
américaines en europe alors que la
france aurait les moyens
mais la france c'est un grand pays est
la partie en conseil de sécurité elle a
le droit de veto elle a la force de
dissuasion l arme atomique
la france malgré le mal qui a été fait
par la politique giscardienne la france
dispose d'un crédit internationale
incontestable par conséquent la france
peut jouer un rôle positif
alors qu'est ce qu'il faut faire il faut
prendre des initiatives que ce soit dans
les instances où déjà on discute de paix
et de désarmement
il faut prendre des initiatives à l'onu
il faut prendre des initiatives à la
conférence de madrid
voilà ce que moi je préconise des
initiatives concrètes pour enclencher
enfin la marche vers le désarmement j'ai
quand même entendu le mot force de
dissuasion
peux-tu en un mot bien préciser notre
position d armement d'accord il faut
assurer la sécurité de la france dans le
monde d'aujourd'hui je le ferai dans nos
îles et il est impensable
naturellement que la france n'assure pas
sa sécurité
mais il n'y a pas de contradiction
d'ailleurs c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous qui sommes des hommes de paix nous
qui sommes pour un monde sans armes et
sans guerre nous n'avons cependant pris
position pour la force de frappe pour la
force de dissuasion
quand nous avons su que les forces de
défense
trad
lionel n'était pas suffisante pour
assurer la sécurité du pays
nous sommes donc pour la force de
dissuasion mais avec ce qu'elle implique
la force de dissuasion c'est pour
empêcher la guerre et tous azimuts c'est
à dire sans adversaire déclarée à l'abri
résumons-nous en un mot tout se tient
dans cette politique
le tiers monde les échanges la paix le
désarmement à la sécurité de la france
s'est basé sur l'idée de l'indépendance
nationale
absolument la france est là bien que
nous appartenions à l'alliance
atlantique jeudi que dans le cadre de
ces alliances
la france doit pratiquer une politique
de non alignement
c'est à dire sans se préoccuper des
super quand elle doit prendre en toute
indépendance et en toute souveraineté
ses propres initiaux ni moscou ni
washington ni bonnes ni notre capital
étranger
les sept cent mille personnes qui ont
participé à tous mes meetings savent que
c'est mon mot d'ordre
alors moi la poésie la france c'est à
paris et nulle part ailleurs qu'elles
doivent d emmanuel masson vosges et veut
intervenir sur cette caisse bien je
voudrais dire ceci en m'adressant aux
agriculteurs mais non pas dans un cadre
corporatiste
je voudrais dire à travers la france que
moi le nom communiste
je vais voter pour georges marchais
parce que le parti communiste représente
actuellement un espoir pour les hommes
c'est le devenir des hommes et dans
cette finalité
je rejoins absolument mes pensées de
chrétiens je le dis très nettement
il a des possibilités d'approché et de
convergence entre nous qui font que je
propres et que je ferai dans la mesure
de mes moyens
faire voter pour georges marchais nous
sommes différents nous trouvons ensemble
dans secundo gardons nos différences
nous et nous avons notre communauté dans
la lutte je dirais même pour ma part
êtes vous d'accord
à ces différences à ce pluralisme nous
tenons comme à la prunelle de nos yeux
il ne serait être autrement question
nous avons commencé d'ailleurs dans la
lutte contre contre le marché commun
contre cette europe douala ne voulons
plus voilà déjà plusieurs années et nous
avons fait un bout de chemin ensemble
dans le respect et on ne m'a jamais
forcé la main pas
l'instant et j'ai toujours agi en tant
que responsable professionnel agricole
au niveau de l'europe
mais là messieurs notre émission se
termine aujourd'hui notre prochain
rendez vous avec georges marchais il est
ce soir à la radio
georges marchais s'entretiendra avec les
jeunes